कि नमस्कार जर्मनी के हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट पाठ में आपका स्वागत है पिछली
वाराणसी के डेकोरेशन यानि वेयर आज हम
सीखेंगे या नहीं क्वेश्चन मतलब यस नो
क्वेश्चन और रिक्वेस्ट है तो चलिए शुरू
करते हैं या नहीं क्वेश्चन लिए कितनी
सिंपल है इसका आंसर यह या नहीं हां या ना
में आता है कि एग्जांपल तुम क्रिकेट खेलते
हो ना तुम्हारा नाम किधर है ना एकदम सिंपल
है उसका नाम की यह ना किधर है
है और तो भी इसका जर्मन कैसे करना है
सिमिलर होगा हमने लास्ट टाइम देखा है
इंग्लिश में आपने कैसे करते इसका
डुप्लिकेट ड्रिंक पी दो यूनिट पिज़्ज़ा और
लास्ट हमने देखा तो डीलिमिटेशन तो जर्मन
में है ही नहीं तो हम उसका कैसे बनाएंगे
डुब्लीकेट डायरेक्टर का यह पीस जो क्रिकेट
अब इंपॉर्टेंट मीटिंग देखो आप कुछ तो यह
स्लो क्वेश्चन पूछ रहे तो इंपोर्टेंट क्या
है पूछना इसीलिए पहले पुलिस इंस्पेक्टर का
या वह इंग्लिश किधर है इंग्लिश में भी
ड्राईवर भी पहले आया था तो हम करेंगे
पिंटू क्रिकेट प्रिंस टूटे या फिर अगर
आपको आदर से पूछना है अगर आपको याद है कि
नरसी की गई थी
कि रिंकल्स डिटेल आप पिज़्ज़ा करते हो
क्या इस संक्षिप्त सर्कल शेप सिंपल है
पहले पोजीशन पर्व व सेकेंड पोजीशन पर लूट
और बाकी सब बाद में
मैं इसी का हम डाल व के लिए भी आगे लेकर
जा सकते हैं कैन यू ईट पिज्जा का क्या
होगा आ का इंच की धूप पिज़्ज़ा एडिसन का
हंटर 2 पिज़्ज़ा एडिशन यह अगर आपको याद
होगा रिएक्शन एंड में ही आएगा तो कुंडल व
कर रहे हैं तो फिर रखता है क्या कंस्ट्रू
पिज्जा एडिसन आप पिज्जा खाते हो क्या
कुंजी पिज़्ज़ा बंसल तू क्रिकेट खेलता है
खेल सकता है क्या
हु क्रिकेटर पिलर
कि आप क्रिकेट खेल सकते हो क्या क्यों न
नजदीक है अगर आप यहां पर देखोगे तुम डाल व
के रूल फॉलो होते हैं कि चलेगा क्या
कांस्टिट्यून और जोशी लख्या एडिसन है वह
एंड में जाएगा अपने इन्फेंट फॉर्म में
रहेगा
मैं इसी का यूज करके हम रिक्वेस्ट सीखने
वाले हैं अगर आपको याद होगा हमने जब मोड
ऑन वर्ग सीखे तो मैंने आपको बोला था मोड
ऑफ बहुत इंपोर्टेंट क्यों क्योंकि जब आप
मोड ऑन कर सीखोगे तो आपको दो चीजें फ्री
मिलेंगी क्वेश्चन आ फ्यूचर टेंस और
रिक्वेस्ट फ्यूचर टेंस कैसे फ्री मिलता है
वह आपने देखा अभी हम देखेंगे रिक्वेस्ट
कैसे फ्री मिलती है आज हम सबको मोड व की
कंसेप्ट यार है तो मंडलगढ़ में हम कैसे
करते हैं आई एम एंड ड्रिंक आईटी
कि इस धार टैंकर इस डिटेल इन अधूरापन चला
और धार्मिक बना प्रियंका एंड मैं अपनी जगह
पर ही रहता और इंफिनिटिव अभी अगर आपको
पूछना है आमिर इन मिट्टी का गण आपको
रिक्वेस्ट बनानी है मेयर एड्रिन फेंटी तो
क्या होगा सिर्फ अदला-बदली कर लूंगी धार
थिस ट्री न सिर्फ इस डायरेक्टिव ट्रेन का
दार पिस ट्विंकल बन गया सिंपल है राइट
प्रिंस खन एंड में ही रहा मेरिट की जो
पिज़्ज़ा एडिसन
शो मे झूट बर्गर और पिज्जा बर्गर स्थल में
क्वाइट डिफिकल्ट सीलन दबिश डाली रिक्वेस्ट
है यू कैन गिव मी एप्पल यू कैन गिव मी पल
जरूरत में होता है वह कैसे होता है या फिर
मुझे यह होता है कैसे होता है ऐसे में
देखेंगे अभी के लिए याद रखना है इस मुझे
यू कैन गिव मी एप्पल आप मुझे दे सकते हो
जी को अनम्यूट एप्पल एप्पल एप्पल एप्पल
मैं किसी का अगर आपको उल्टा करना है
क्योंकि उन्हें एप्पल तो क्या होगा का
यूनिवर्सिटी में है पहली कुंठा से कुछ भी
मांग सकते हैं नंदी जी को भी चीज वहां पर
धुंध लौटे तो यह रिक्वेस्ट है कि मैं कुछ
ले सकता हूं कि आप मुझे कुछ देख सकते हो
कि जहां अलग बना सकते हो आप मेरी हेल्प कर
सकते हो या फिर कि आखिर खोल सकते हो नंद
सब्सक्राइब पर यह सब जैसे आप नए वर्ग
बताऊंगी इंपॉर्टेंट रिक्वेस्ट किया है अगर
आप
इस चरण में आ जाते हो तो एक चाहे बोलने से
ज्यादा फ्लैग ज्यादा मैजिकल क्या है इन
थिस टाइम थे यहां पर या फिर क्यों धीमे
झील यह ज्यादा पोलाइट तो आए हो आप सबको
रिक्वेस्ट समझ में आए हैं दो इंपोर्टेंट
पार्ट दांत इसकी स्याही बंद या कुंठा या
पिंपल तो इस पाठ में हमने सीखा लें यस नो
क्वेश्चन और रिक्वेस्ट चमक हो रिवाइज करते
हैं पहली चीज हमको इंग्लिश की तरह डालकर
कंसेप्ट है ही नहीं जर्मन में बतौर
डायरेक्टर उठोगे तू क्रिकेट खेलता है क्या
फील स्टूपिड या फिर आप क्रिकेट खेलते हो
क्या पिन थी क्रिकेट
कि इसका एवं उड़द और में कर सकते हैं कैन
यू प्ले क्रिकेट का लड्डू क्रिकेट स्पीड
है या फिर आप क्रिकेट खेल सकते हैं क्या
क्यों रणजी क्रिकेट क्लब और उसी का यूज
करके मोड व का यूज करके हमने रिक्वेस्ट
बनाने से कि दो इंपॉर्टेंट मुझे रिक्वेस्ट
हंस हैं डार्क फी सहावर या फिर चैनल धीमी
गति साकिब अन आई हॉप आपको यस नो क्वेश्चन
और रिक्वेस्ट ठीक से समझ में आए होंगे हम
मिलेंगे नेक्स्ट पर में धन्यवाद